Hi i'm scott lang um well you might know
me as ant-man and i am hopeful the wasp
look before we start let me
address the elephant in the room
i've heard a lot of chatter out there
asking why i didn't shrink down go in and
kill thanos in a really creative way first of
all gross secondly it's much more complicated
than that allow me to explain if only we had the
time Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new video for all the ant-man and all the new
avengers footage that just dropped everybody's
asking all kinds of questions what is this canon
to love that they mentioned so much thanos in
this like why didn't i fly up thanos's butt well
here's why i'll explain what's going on here what
this is cannon two because this is meant to be a
little bit different from the timeline that you're
seeing in the mcu right now like in the mcu ms
marvel hasn't met the new falcon captain america
she hasn't met captain marvel yet she hasn't
met any of the other avengers characters yet
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there's a
bunch of big stuff coming up and thor love and
thunder is hitting theaters next week so we're
doing a giveaway for imax tickets all you
have to do to enter is just be a subscriber
and post your favorite moment from all this brand
new ant-man in avengers footage on the video
the big joke here obviously everyone was just
talking about the famous joke that them actually
trying to canonize that like this is why i did
not fly up thanos's butt if you don't remember
a couple years ago this turned into like a really
huge thing like interviewers started asking the
russo brothers doing the big press interviews
for avengers infinity war in avengers 10 game
and they had to sit there and answer questions
about thanos butt in fact it was such a big deal
that they just did a parody of it during the boys
season 3 episode 1 but with an even more wtf twist
like in the boys version i can't include it in
this video totally just because it's so gross they
did it as more of a front door kind of thing than
a backdoor kind of thing just to give you an idea
if you saw you know what i'm talking about
it was that gross like they fully went there
but i know everyone's asking what's going on
with these new avengers scenes like the new
ant-man scenes what is this canon 2 because like
i said this is kind of meant to be a separate
timeline from what they're doing in the mcu
movies right now but this is all the actors
coming back to reprise their characters
shooting a bunch of new footage for this
so the actual ant-man the new avengers footage
features ant-man hope van dyne wasp a new avengers
bass anthony mackey's new captain america the
brand new ms marvel kamala khan who also meets
captain marvel during the footage or just sees
her in the distance and barely misses meeting her
all battling a version of ultron who has
returned in a bunch of big quantum tech in this
presentation they're doing called miracles from
molecules as part of a new avengers tech showcase
and because he references thanos that means
that avengers infinity war the snap happened
during this timeline so whichever universe this
is taking place in this is set like the furthest
forward in the future of the mcu timeline that
we've been so far except for like the loki series
that's kind of like an exception because they
literally go to the end of the actual timeline
but if you're just talking about the stuff that
takes place in present day like this would be
the furthest forward in the timeline aside from
what's happening here thor love and thunder is
meant to be the furthest forward in the timeline
that we've been in taiko batiti said that that's
meant to take place as many years after avengers
end game as we've had since the movie came out so
even though the mcu is kind of like time shifted
like it starts at 2023 and moves forward from that
because it's been about three years after avengers
end game came out it's meant to be 2026 during the
events of thor love and thunder i'll talk more
about all those easter eggs and everything that's
going on during that movie when i post all those
thor love and thunder videos next week when the
movie comes out so don't worry about that but
like even though captain marvel for instance is
probably going to have some kind of cameo scene
of some kind in the ms marvel finale that episode
hasn't even gotten close to airing yet like
currently in the mcu ms marvel has never actually
met captain marvel and she's never met the falcon
captain america or any of the other avengers for
that matter so that's why marvel is basically
explaining this like it's meant to be an alternate
universe continuity like the 838 universe and
doctor strange 2 is a completely separate timeline
of events they experience a similar version of
events but very different characters and slightly
different events happen during them like they
have full-blown x-men inhumans fantastic four in
that universe all this brand new footage for the
avengers that they created for something called
avengers quantum encounter and it's like this
big real life event that people participate in
just happening in an alternate universe i don't
know what the actual number of their universe is
like they just canonized the main mcu as the 616
universe like the comic book 616 universe this one
would be a different number in the first clip they
just have a funny moment where he jokes about why
he didn't do the things to win avengers infinity
war because reasons mostly the fans usually wind
up coming up with better theories than you wind up
seeing play out in the actual movies but in this
new avengers bass they teach the viewers how
to shrink stuff using pym particles and these
new quantum cores that they're calling it's just
meant to be quantum tech that they use to harness
quantum energy they're supposed to shrink down
some of his luggage you notice on his luggage
he's got an x-con sticker from the company that
he ran with his friends he's got a pymtech sticker
and it believed the other stickers for the old
stark expo that you saw in iron man 2. they also
have this new mechanical ant base flying robot
here that you could probably buy as real merch
in the footage you notice that they're also using
friday iron man's ai so apparently after iron
man dies in this universe they just continue
using friday like the avengers continue using
him they have a joke about ant-man messing up the
quantum tech and making one of the seagulls nearby
giant size he makes a couple jokes about captain
america captain marvel and captain crunch
mentioning the first two because those characters
literally show up in the video right after this
then right on cue falcon captain america shows
up they bring back that joke about everybody
calling him the wrong name like ant-man calls him
captain falcon just like the little kid did during
that scene in falcon and winter soldier they also
referenced the new avengers base a couple times
i'm assuming this is meant to be a different base
from the last avengers base in upstate new york
there have been a couple new avengers scenes in
the mcu like in the shangshit post credit scene
but it wasn't inside any kind of new avengers base
like all the characters were just basically doing
advanced skype sessions inside comartage captain
america says that he ms marvel and captain marvel
have showed up because they detected ultron and
his ultron bots he's calling ms marvel the kid
which is meant to be a joke on what they used to
call spider-man when they first met him in civil
war like he was the kid because he was so young
even though this is taking place much later in the
timeline when she's already met the other avengers
characters at least during the ms marvel series
she's meant to be about the same age spider-man
was during spider-man far from home because she's
a junior in high school like she has one more
year after this and they pay off the joke about
her making all the avengers videos on her social
media accounts and her sloth baby youtube channel
only now she's doing actual avengers stuff in
this timeline so it's not just fan fiction videos
she's also still got the bangle which kind of
makes it sound like after the ms marvel series
is over she'll still have the bangle and they
won't wind up perma destroying it and it's just
the one bengal which is comic book accurate
like in the comics she only wears one bangle
even though on the ms marvel series they tease
this whole thing with a totally different
bangle like there's a second bangle that can
give someone even more power captain america
also makes fun of her doing the same thing that
iron man did to spider-man and avengers infinity
war just yelling at her to stop making so many
pop culture references like stop making references
he also confirms that she's still on temporary
probationary status with the new avengers like
we'll see how things go and maybe eventually
we'll let you join the avengers officially
i think that's going to be the idea with a lot of
the brand new really young characters that they
introduce like it sounds like they're working
up to a young avengers project on the side but
there's also all the regular avengers stuff like
the new avengers movie whatever avengers 5 winds
up being which itself is also another call back
to spider-man wanting to be an avenger so badly
during infinity war and iron man kind of not
caring about it like okay you want to be an
avenger you're an avenger fine here you go kid
congratulations like iron man is worried about
saving the universe he could care less about
spider-man actually being on the avengers
they get into a big fight with ultron's bots you
see ms marvel use her powers obviously they look
just like the way she uses her powers during the
ms marvel series just a little bit more advanced
because this is later in the timeline and she's
got her full comic book costume already you also
notice they included a wilhelm scream they don't
put it in every single star wars movie or every
single marvel movie but it shows up in a lot of
them then they bring back ultron and the person
who's playing ultron isn't james spader but it
probably sounds familiar it's meant to be the same
ultron actor from the what if episodes that was
also ross mark hand who played red skull during
avengers infinity war in avengers end game and
then captain marvel shows up to help them finish
off the ultron bots making a reference about how
she has to go back to the cree part of the galaxy
to take care of another fight which is another
joke about how she's never around on planet earth
they referenced that during the ms marvel series
too like she's meant to be this big fan girl of
captain marvel but this whole part of the intro
for the first episode was her speculating about
why she wasn't around in ant-man's podcast
that's right ant-man has a podcast in the mcu
now which is canon where he talks about a lot of
captain marvel stuff so apparently there's been
some other adventures and some stuff has played
out that we haven't seen on screen yet they'll
probably cover a lot of that stuff when we get
to the captain marvel 2 the marvel's movie and
right as she takes off ms marvel shows up asking
all kinds of captain marvel questions asking if
she's used her binary powers her other major
comic book abilities if you're not a big comic
book reader captain marvel's binary ability is
actually just a form that she takes when she's
so full of energy it's like her most powerful
form she gives off the same amount of energy as
a binary star we'll also probably see that during
the marvel's movie and then they treat it like
ultron has stolen hank pym's quantum tech his pym
particles and they have to stop him which they do
but because marvel is coming to comic con this
summer i know a lot of you are asking what kind
of trailers are they gonna show off at the panel
i think the only big marvel trailer they're going
to show up is going to be the black panther 2
trailer and the rest of the stuff will just be
like previews of ant-man 3 quantum mania in the
other upcoming marvel movies kevin feige did say
that they reveal more of their grand plans for
what's happening with time runs out secret words
all the incursions so we will find out about a
bunch of other stuff but like the only actual
real big trailer they'll officially release i
think is going to be black panther 2. there might
be some other footage that they don't release
publicly but of course i'll do videos for all that
stuff so don't worry i just did a whole bunch of
videos on doctor doom their bunch of easter eggs
during doctor strange too there were a bunch of
announcements in real life you can click here to
learn all about those and click here for my brand
new thor love and thunder trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!